what's up everybody i am one half of the
wwe women's tag team champion the legit
abbas wwe superstar sasha banks and
these are some of my favorite snacks
[Music]
so my first favorite snack is
now i am a what i say a health freak or
i just like eating clean nuts are so
good for you they're good in
antioxidants
inflammation and if you just need a
quick fix of energy especially when
you're really low a handful of nuts is
the way to go
i like that rhyme
oh my beautiful nail no
well my flower came off me
it's hard to be a superstar in nails and
look cute but
i've had some peanuts in a long time
let's see what's next on the list i know
it's coming up oh they are just flat you
guys love me so much if you're my best
friend in the world you know that i love
chicken wings any time i am on the road
and it's super super late night the only
thing that i usually see on uber is
mcdonald's which is ant ain't gonna do
it burger king not but wings yes yes yes
i get so excited if i see wings because
i get in at like 12 two in the morning
wings are what i order every single week
and these are lemon peppers so these
look so good
i don't know where you got these from
but these are good flat chicken wings
are just perfect for me it just has just
a little bit of meat is cooked well and
you can make it extra crispy and i like
to like that
now my next favorite snack every single
day i love a good bowl of fruit i love
bananas
time before there's a match every
smackdown every raw every pay-per-view i
am in catering and i am the gorilla in
there grabbing the bunch of bananas and
i am chowing on it before i go for my
matches if it's bananas
pineapples strawberries and then that's
just the last couple years i've really
began to love pineapple i used to hate
it as a kid i used to gag when i was
around and now i've just grown to love
it because you know i learned the
benefits of it
it was really good for you you know
hey
mmm
this is so good yogurt buffet sangria
that's my favorite way to have fruit
i love fruit and sangria so a go-to
since i was a kid because i grew up with
no food no nothing
it's always a good bowl of white rice
and some hot sauce what kind of hot
sauce is this it's not the last dab
right just classic hot sauce perfect
gotta dab that on there
now this is like a go-to snack when i'm
at home and it's just really quick easy
and i'm always on the go so i ain't got
time so a minute rice only takes a
minute and it takes a second to grab a
hot sauce you dab it on there that's
five more seconds
that was so good it's classic make sure
you get some
now i see something amazing coming up
anytime there's a celebration aka
every time i'm at home aka once a week
aka maybe once in a month but i love me
a good shot
of mezcal
oh my god now i've been to mexico
plenty of times and i can tell you
when i was 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
i can down
a bottle of mezcal now now that i'm 30
i'm i'm pushing back a little bit
i'm down to doing half a bottle now
oh my god it smells so good it smells so
good
let's see should i get myself a tamina
shot
perfect
and with mezcal you know you shouldn't
really take it as a shot like tequila
shot or a vodka shot it's more of a
sipper if you need to enjoy it
do we have any um
oh yes
with mezcal you just can't sip it alone
you have to have
oranges
and not just that
crickets
i know i know you're saying what yes
crickets are so good for you and in
mexico it's just a known tradition to
have your mezcal with crickets
very salty
it tastes like um a sunflower seed
that's what it tastes like
then we have the mezcal
oh my
mama's home
this is the best snack in the world
it makes me feel so good inside i feel
like a fire breathing dragon i feel
alive
hey hey
you know i haven't got to celebrate my
wrestlemania one yet so this
was a celebration to myself
cheers to me and my tag team partner
nyomi you gotta get you some some
crickets when you have some mescal now
and that's how you do it like a boss
[Music]
this is the legit boss sasha banks and
thank you so much for watching that was
my favorite snacks and make sure you
watch me every single week on raw and
smackdown
cheers
[Music]